[Musique]
elles sont irrésistibles impossible de
la manger qu'une seule et elle ne reste
pas longtemps dans leur cacher la
croustille vraiment un aliment plaisir
d'abord et avant tout est dans la façon
dont les marques se commercialisent
qu'elle communique les emballages sont
créés on est vraiment dans l'univers du
plaisir et de l'attirance le plus
possible son très très colorés des
couleurs très vibrante très attirant
c'est vraiment savoir marc vous chaque
mois
les j'aime ça quand ça pète crunch puis
que ça goûte salée puis un petit peu
groupe c'est comme le mélange de ces
trois choses là qui nous rendent si
joyeux fous pourquoi on été conçu et
l'ange magique la texture le gras et le
sel vont danser nos papilles et stimuler
certaines rondes de plaisir particulière
dans le cerveau qui fait en sorte
en fait on a juste envie d'en manger
encore et encore
la consommation de gras de sel et de
sucre activé à notre cerveau des
hormones qui sont associés au plaisir
dans ces produits là il ya vraiment les
considérations qui sont mises pour
essayer de nous faire perdre le contrôle
depuis les années 60 l'industrie élabore
de nouveaux produits
en se basant sur le modèle du psycho
physicien howard moskowitz c'est la
courbe du point de féliciter le point de
féliciter c'est le point à laquelle la
saveur de l'aliment va maximiser le
plaisir en bouche en deçà de ce point là
la quantité de sucre de sel n'est pas
suffisante pour plaire aux consommateurs
et au delà de ce point là bas il ya trop
de sel de sucre donc ça déplaît aux
consommateurs donc le point de féliciter
c'est vraiment le la quantité parfaite
d'ingrédients qui veut maximiser le
plaisir en bouche puis l'industrie c'est
très bien que nos besoins sont limitées
mais nos désirs eux sont illimitées
lorsque vous mangez des aliments sains
comme des fruits des légumes vous allez
manger jusqu'à temps que vous vous êtes
plein donc vous avez des signaux de
satiété qui vont rentrer en fonction
mais lorsque vous consommez pour
satisfaire vos désirs et ceci est faite
via la l'utilisation du sucre du gros et
du sel
vous pouvez continuer à consommer
jusqu'à l'infini
parce que nos désirs sont infimes puis
on s'en rend même pas compte
non
selon me hocine 96 % des foyers
canadiens achètent en moyenne un sac de
croustilles par semaine ce n'est donc
pas un hasard si on leur donne autant d'
espaces dans les allées d'épicerie bon
il ya beaucoup de marques beaucoup de
produits mais ironiquement yapo tente de
compagnie derrière tous le grand joueur
qui domine vraiment notable est au
canada
s'écrie tollet frito lay qui est une
division de pepsico la remarque fort la
lysine qu'on connaît très bien mais
frito lay est aussi derrière les doritos
et tostitos les cheaters les sound
shapes lyss be qui lèvera folle et on
introduit constamment de nouveaux
produits faut comprendre que l'industrie
doit constamment augmenter ses profits à
chaque trimestre pour le faire elle a
besoin que les consommateurs mangent
toujours plus
mais avant de les mettre dans notre
bouche il faut les mettre dans notre
panier c'est pourquoi les entreprises
font preuve d'une grande créativité pour
leur mise en marché
nous avons classé les marques populaires
en trois catégories
on en fait ce que j'appellerai notre
classique je pense nature sel et
vinaigre ketchup barbecue et une des
stratégies intéressantes dans cette
catégorie là c'est que les fabricants en
parallèle de ces classiques l'homme vont
piquer notre curiosité on continue avec
des nouvelles saveurs et les entreprises
donc le savent que le sentiment de
culpabilité qui est associé avec la
consommation de croustilles pour bien
des gens donc depuis des années on nous
propose des variations sur le thème
donc on repart du classico en relève à
pedro on enlève un peu de sel voilà qu
on en offre aussi à base de légumes non
la du plein et de la carotte de la
betterave
oui c'est fait avec la betterave mais
quand on regarde le pourcentage de
lipides en tête à 21 grammes pour 50
grimpe et ici on est à 18 grammes pour
180 personnes c'est moins gros que ça
par contre ça c'est plus à l'est c'est
une expérience gustative qui est
différente c'est intéressant c'est un
autre goût est-ce que c'est plus santé
est-ce que c'est plus nutritifs pois
vraiment ça reste très grave
certaines marques jouent la carte du
raffinement dans dix couleurs qui nous
donne n'était qu'un effet au diam qu'on
n'avait pas l'habitude de voir dans la
catégorie et aussi ils ont choisi
d'utiliser une variété de légumes
racines qui une fois tranchée sont
vraiment magnifiques servir ce dans un
bol c'est chic chic ou pas elles sont
grasses comme c'est le cas de la plupart
des croustilles en effet pour une
portion d'une vingtaine de chip la
majorité des produits de notre analyse
contiennent entre 12 et 18 gramme de
matière grasse et quand on parle de 18
le chu autour du corps de mes besoins
quotidiens en matières grasses dans une
portion
si vous regardez
d'où viennent les calories vous allez
voir que dans un sac de croustilles les
calories viennent d'abord de l'huile
ensuite des pommes de terre donc
concrètement on mange de l'huile
assaisonné d'un morceau de pomme de
terre avec du sel jeunes est rayé contre
la pomme de terre mais une fois qu'elle
est et frites airs frites et en fait
dans l'huile ce qu'il ya de bon dans la
pomme de terre y en as pu enfin la
nouvelle tendance les gothiques
collation
[Musique]
parce que l'on parle de fibres on parle
de protéines pour vrai donc à la rigueur
même certaines ces produits là sont plus
nutritifs et nourrissant que des cracks
lundi je prends cet exemple là où on
l'écrit clairement en façade 6 g de
protéines 6 grammes de fibres c'est pas
des attributs qu'on retrouve normalement
sur les crocs cité irrégulière donc
c'est très élevé qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on a autant de fibres ou de protéines
dans ces produits là c'est vraiment la
présence comme ingrédient principal de
légumineuses
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'elles sont
riches en fibres et protéines que
certaines d'entre elles ne sont pas
grasse et ça les aide aussi
donc la plupart sont des gens sont sales
et son bon sauf à claude sahi chrono
l'idée n'est pas d'enlever le plaisir et
puis de danger juste sainement mais de
faire attention peut-être sur l' on est
dans une des balances donc on est dans
une société où les aliments les plus
malsains tu domines il faudrait que ce
soit l'inversé
j'ai envie de dire si vous aimez
vraiment ça assumer et essayer de
développer un peu plus de conscience de
la quantité que vous vous trouvez à
manger parce que dans le fond le vrai
piège il le meilleur truc qu'on répète
souvent c servez-vous une portion et
sari le sac parce qu'on sait qu'avec le
point de féliciter il est difficile
d'arrêter et pas certes et alors que
notre corps va ensuite nous féliciter
[Musique]